100 minutos en los que fue dificilísimo
seguir los argumentos de uno y otro lado
por las numerosas interrupciones que
hubo en el debate entre el presidente
del gobierno y candidato del partido
socialista Pedro Sánchez y el líder de
la oposición y candidato del partido
popular Alberto Núñez feijo que lideran
las encuestas de Voto para las generales
del 23 de Julio el único cara a cara que
habrá en esta campaña electoral y el
único debate en el que participe feijó
la primera mitad se centró en economía y
política social aquí uno de los temas
con mayor tensión fue el de la violencia
machista en lo que va de año 28 mujeres
han sido asesinadas en España por sus
parejas y mientras que Sánchez criticaba
Los pactos en distintas regiones
españolas del partido popular con la
ultraderecha vox que minimiza los
feminicidios feijo recriminó la ley del
solo sí es sí que causó la excarcelación
de más de 100 agresores sexuales los
pactos de gobierno un tema molesto para
ambos pero clave en los comicios ya que
ningún partido mayoritario tiene lo
suficientes votos para gobernar en
solitario prota el tercer bloque del
debate feijos Se comprometió a que si
saca más votos el partido socialista
escenario poco probable según las
encuestas facilitará su gobierno su
gobierno y al preguntarle a Sánchez si
haría lo mismo el presidente del
gobierno no contestó y recriminó que
esto de la lista más votada no se
aplique en las regionales El Sahara
occidental la independencia de Cataluña
fueron algunos de los temas de la última
parte del encuentro Bronco en el que
Sánchez finalizó comparando el posible
pacto de partido popular con vox con un
túnel del tiempo tenebroso mientras que
feijo pidió el voto masivo para acabar
con un gobierno de bloques el 19 de
julio se dará un nuevo debate electoral
Eso sí sin la presencia de fe yjo porque
solo han aceptado acudir el líder del
partido socialista Pedro Sánchez el
líder de la hasta ahora tercera fuerza
política vox Santiago abascal y de la
cuarta fuerza política el nuevo grupo de
izquierdas liderado por Yolanda Díaz el
grupo sumar